only on CBS this morning a reporter is
sharing her story after she says she was
assaulted during her live TV report the
video has been viewed more than 10
million times people also dress up in
costumes for this bridge run I'm so it's
very exciting it's very exciting um
people
Alex Bazar Jean was covering a fun run
for her Savannah Georgia station that's
WS AV on Saturday and you can see one of
the runners a man in a blue long sleeve
t-shirt as he moves behind her and
appears to slap her on her backside
bizarre Xion tweeted this following that
incident to the man who smacked my butt
on live TV you violated objectified and
embarrassed me she's also filed a police
report yesterday and the man has been
banned from future races and Alex joins
us now Alex good morning good morning so
the video tells almost the whole story
you can see your reaction but what were
you thinking that reaction is so price
it says so much what was going through a
head that moment had happened well the
moment it happened you know you you're
in disbelief yeah you you feel like did
did that really just happen so took some
time to process but it was extremely
vulnerable you know and I think I would
say that the reason why you know maybe I
caught so much fire is because the
emotion is extremely relatable for women
all over the world not only for
journalists working on TV but for women
in general this is a workplace issue
right right you say that slap actually
stung yeah yeah it was a heavy impact
it's been very deliberate - when you're
watching it right it's very very
deliberate right yeah I mean it was I
mean if you of course watch the video
multiple times because you look at it
and it feels like it's not you it's like
you're watching somebody else but he
separates himself from the runners and
he kind of winds up and um you know he
hit me hard I mentioned that it's
delivered because isn't he saying it was
an accident that he didn't do it on
purpose
the tape certainly tells a very
different story right yeah he did try to
you know make contact with our
station with the station that I work
with and you know kind of you know was
saying that his intentions were not you
know to hurt me he didn't intend to do
it which you know not gonna really
debate that because he hurt me
but now that you've had time to think
about it cuz at first you are stung
clearly startled
are you angry frustrated saddened by it
what are you thinking I think
immediately after after you kind of sort
through the vulnerability of the
situation you are inundated with some
female guilts kills that's interesting
guilt Alex why um I guess maybe because
of all of the social media attention of
course there's been an outpouring of
support from so many people men women
you know people of all ages you've also
had people though say accept the apology
move on you said right yeah
accept the apology it's your fault you
put yourself in the line of fire and a
line of fire yeah essentially just I
mean maybe that comes from a
misunderstanding of what live or doing
your job you have a statement from yeah
we need to read these lawyers the
runners lawyer sent a statement saying
they regret the situation but he quote
did not act with any criminal intentions
that he's a loving husband and father
and they don't expect any criminal
charges are you open to hearing what he
has to say I think what is most
important here is that he took my power
and I'm trying to take that back
and whether I am open to it or not I
want to take my time with that and I
think what it really comes down to is
that he helped himself to a part of my
body I think I think took my power is a
really powerful phrase because there are
people and you've heard from them who
are saying what's the big deal
you know he was being rambunctious real
quickly because we do have to go what's
the reaction to those people my reaction
to that quickly coke will take the
social media will get that reaction
alright well and we'll be right back